is t-birds are turning in their hockey
sticks for golf clubs this summer and
you can join them we have head coaches
corey ward and joe sullivan here to tell
us more about their inaugural t-bird
classic golf tournament that's cool the
very first one how you guys feeling
about that we're excited we're excited
hopefully uh we get a nice turn out so
okay i think you will i think you will
now let's talk about the t-birds first
and foremost you know who are you guys
introduce us to the team um so las vegas
t-birds uh we're a junior a hockey club
okay
um only in the city only junior hockey
team in las vegas um
junior hockey what it is essentially is
our players are ages 15 to 20 years old
essentially they are playing to get
scout to play college hockey is a little
bit unique as opposed to football and
basketball where it's not the
traditional high school to college road
okay um hockey we have junior hockey
which is in that step in between um so
like i said our players are all
competing to kind of earn some
scholarships go to school well thank you
for doing that for our kids and let's do
the hockey skills translate to the golf
course for you too
people say they do um i'm still not very
good right we're still learning but i
mean it's still kind of the same shot
but um for our tournament we're really
just trying to build awareness and kind
of fundraise make a little bit of money
to help out an expensive sport perfect
well that's the perfect segue to
explaining the golf tournament and how
people can join so they can go onto
lvtbshockey.com that has a bunch of
information about our team
photos our game schedule and there's
also a link for our golf tournament and
pretty much what it is it's a fun day
where we get a good turnout
first and foremost we're building money
because hockey's an expensive sport not
every family can afford to send their
kids from quebec and all these places to
play for us so it helps pay for travel
our trainers to make them have a very
good comfortable experience in las vegas
and we get to have a little bit of fun
on the golf course as well absolutely
and this is all happening august 12th so
there's plenty of time to register of
course
and
in terms of the t-birds and the team you
know how can we catch you guys when does
the season start
so our season will begin uh we have our
main camp august 25th to 28th um that
will be what we select our team based
out of
after that we kind of hit the ground
running from there so we'll start
practice that first week in september
and we will have our home game our first
home game i believe is the third week of
september
we play in between lifeguard arena out
in henderson and then city national on
the west side and what's the energy like
you know watching you guys play i know
hockey gets crazy
yeah i'd say so junior hockey's a little
bit different again you know the nhl or
youth hockey it's a very fun atmosphere
um it's only ten dollars to go um our
fans do get a little bit rowdy um but
it's definitely that in between from
college hockey and youth hockey so you
do get some very good talent and our
games are really really exciting okay
well i'm excited to see the turnout for
the t-birds classic golf tournament
august 12th it is going to be at a royal
golf club in summerlin again friday
august 12th at 7 a.m starting at 7am